is everyone connected
well good afternoon and thank you for
joining us
on the second day of this european
council summit
we will shortly be releasing the
conclusions
on both topics on our website and let me
first give the floor to the president of
the european
[Music]
student topic on the agenda today was
climate change we prepared this
european council we had a lot of
consultations before
and we had the opportunity
all the delegations to express
priorities
concerns legitimate concerts in order to
to take into consideration this process
and the responsibility
of the commission that will put on the
table in the next two tweaks
concrete legislative proposals and we
trust the permission to take
this into account we had important
discussions on different topics
ets effort sharing carbon adjustment
mechanism
the importance to take into
consideration the different starting
points
in the different countries and we if we
affirmed
our common goals which are ambitious
climate neutrality by 2050 but also
the decisions that we have taken in
december last year
uh the uh decreased by
55 percent at least 55 of our emissions
by 2030.
um this is a very complex debate
with many areas which are interconnected
it's important to the global vision it's
also important to take into
consideration
the impact assessment for the different
member states
and you can be certain that we will
continue to work
a lot with the member states with the
commission with the european parliament
this process and in preparation of the
next cup 26
in glasgow we hope it'll be possible for
the european union
to continue to play a leading role in to
be to be a concrete in order to make
to make progress
thank you madam president thank you
thank you very much indeed our primary
focus at this
european council at this point in time
continues to be the fight against the
pandemic
both inside the european union and of
course also outside the european union
in the european union it is undeniable
that we have made
great progress since the beginning of
may
we see cases and hospitalizations on a
downward trend that is good
by the end of the week over 300 million
doses of vaccines will have been
delivered to member states
and in june we expect more than 400
million doses
so we are on track to reach our goal
to have enough doses being delivered
to vaccinate 70 percent of the adult
population
in the european union by the end of july
if we continue like this we have
confidence that we will be able to
safely
reopen our societies so we must now
focus on consolidating this progress
one important element that we've been
discussing is the vaccination of minors
we hope for emma to approve
the biotech pfizer vaccines for 12
to 15 year old children
which will then make the vaccination
possible
another topic that we have been
discussing is of course the possibility
of escape variance
vaccines are showing effectiveness
against the known variants present in
europe that's a good
result but of course we know that escape
variance will remain a public health
risk and we are therefore working
hard on setting up an efficient
monitoring
of escape variants for the european
union
the ecdc is monitoring closely the
circulation of variants
within the eu and it is now important
that it expands its monitoring to
a global scale because this will help
stay us presumably one step ahead
of a virus and adapt our strategies
quickly in case that this
is necessary this is all the more
important as we progress
with reopening our societies and in
particular
as we progress in facilitating freedom
of movement
across the european union and indeed
there is then the eu certificate
that plays a role we are very happy that
the political agreement last week
has taken place it marks a major
milestone in this respect
citizens will now be able to use a
mutually recognized certificate
wherever they travel in the european
union
the it infrastructure is ready
at eu level as of june 1st
and as of mid-june when the regulation
enters into force
member states will be able to connect
life to the system
now member states have the key and the
urgent task
to make sure that the national health
systems are fed
with the information of citizens health
status
so that the certificate can be issued
sounds like a lot of work and indeed it
is still a lot of work
but i'm optimistic that we're getting
there i think the certificate
is a unique opportunity to showcase how
the european union
contributes concretely to people's daily
lives
so we must all contribute to make it
happen
on the global response indeed we have
been discussing
on one hand the vaccine sharing
mechanism
and as you know beginning last week
member states have
started to pledge to donate vaccines
which is all the more timely as we know
that
the serum institute of india has halted
all its export to covers until the end
of the year so donations are desperately
needed
and there's a second good news that our
european industrial partners that is
biotech pfizer and modern and johnson
johnson
have committed to deliver 1.3 billion
doses of vaccines in 2021
at non-profit for low-income countries
and at low-cost
to middle-income countries and finally
indeed
we are working on an initiative to
invest one billion euro from team europe
to develop vaccine manufacturing in
africa
the capacity itself in africa it's a
specific initiative with our
african partners initiative not only for
the production
so to build up the manufacturing
capacities but also for
skilled development for the management
of the supply chain
or for example the necessary regulatory
framework through the african
medicines agency this
initiative also aims at bringing mrna
technologies to africa this is something
which hasn't happened so far but
this is our aim to get there
the second topic we've been discussing
indeed is climate
and uh over the past year we have made
growth grow
great progress in charting our course to
climate neutrality in 2050
and as you know we fixed the inter
intermediary target
of minus at least minus 55 percent
of greenhouse gas emissions till 2030.
now uh we have shown to the european uh
council that we are building a model for
a clean economy
that is also a prosperous economy and
both is doable a clean economy and a
prosperous
economy that is our goal today we have
continued the discussions on the
necessary means to achieve these goals
the goals are clear they are fixed in
the climate law so nobody is disputing
that
anymore now we have to discuss the how
how we are getting there
and the discussion this discussion came
very timely because indeed it is a few
weeks before the commission will present
its package
of proposals so it's both timely and
urgent
that we had this discussion one key
element of the proposals
of the fit455 package
is that we will provide
additional eu level measures along
those alongside those of the member
states to help them
to deliver on the targets so this whole
package will consist of 12
different proposals it will combine on
one hand the
carbon pricing what we know as emission
trading system
the ets that is in place it has proven
to be effective it works and on the
other side
it has the targets and the regulatory
standards for example represented
in the effort sharing regulation
important
is that all these different uh
co2 pricing the regulatory framework the
targets
are closely interlinked they are
interlinked
and they have all the same goal that on
one hand we produce
emissions on the other hand we drive
green
innovation and we foster the necessary
investments
to achieve these goals what we want is
sustainable
clean growth and jobs
in this overall framework we have
discussed the two main
components it is the ets indeed and it
is the complementary
effort sharing regulation i have
listened
very carefully to member states views
about how we do this effectively
and fairly some of these measures may
have
social impacts and therefore it is
important from the very beginning
that we think of models
that we are able to support member
states to ensure
a proper social compensation the one
goes with the other
in some we have our goals fixed now and
agreed as i said the climate
law we are now with this regulatory
framework putting in place
all the necessary measures that we need
to reach
these goals and we have mobilized the
necessary
resources the funding to make it work
through the mff
and next generation eu i think this will
boost public and private investment
into the green transition both
investments for
people and for technology thanks
thank you madam president we are first
going to take a question
by uh angela morrow from the huffington
post angela
are you with us thanks marin for the
floor i have two questions one is on
climate
and the question is uh did you have
more expectations because as far as i
understand this
uh summit uh ends with no indications
for the commission for the package that
you're going to present on 14th of july
if you can